what about bishop d8  yeah feels like black should be all  right it's just one pawn  we have the bishops  and this guy here queen b7 is played  um  rehearse  really thinking okay i'll i'll ask some  questions if you know all the answers  jan  will be draw today it's the good old and  absolutely the case  queen e4 blitzed out the bomb machine  not very surprised he must have repeated  all these sidelines and tries like a  million times preparing for magnus knows  so  to touch him in something direct here  i think it's not gonna work well maybe  richard will play his seventh draw  today he might force it  that'd be news in a very short  time queen a8  so what's the move now  bishop plate is bishop d6  bishops